WITH AMERICA DAYS.
>> President Trump: IS VERY
GOOD.
>> Sean: SCOTT ASKED ME TO
SEND.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT SOME OF
JOE BIDEN’S POSITION THAT HAVE
CHANGED.
I MENTIONED HE WAS AGAINST THE
TRAVEL BAN, SAID IT WAS A GREAT
DECISION, HE WAS AGAINST ALL
FRACKING.
A LOT OF DENIAL ON THE ISSUE OF
THE VIOLENCE AND RIOTS AND
ANARCHY IN CITIES, AND ONE POINT
SAID THE POLICE BECOME THE
ENEMY, REALLOCATE FUNDS,
ET CETERA, ET CETERA, NOW HE IS
TALKING ABOUT EVEN MANUFACTURING
JOBS, WHEN WHEN HE WAS
VICE PRESIDENT AND OBAMA WAS
PRESIDENT, THEY SAID THOSE JOBS
AIN’T COMING BACK.
>> President Trump: THAT’S
RIGHT.
>> Sean: DO YOU THINK AMERICA
AMERICA --
>> President Trump: SEAN COME
I’VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING QUITE
LIKE IT.
THE TRAVEL BAN, ALL OF A SUDDEN,
HE DENIES THAT, THINK THAT WAS
FINE, THINKS IT WAS GOOD.
BUT HOW ABOUT FRACKING?
AND YOU NEED THAT, IT IS
BASICALLY YOUR FOSSIL FUELS,
YOUR ENERGIES.
WE WOULD HAVE TO CLOSE MANY OF
THE PLANTS, A BIG PERCENTAGE OF
THE PLANTS IN OUR COUNTRY IF WE
DIDN’T DO THIS.
WE HAVE THESE MASSIVE PLANTS AND
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO RUN BY
WIND AND NOT BY SOLAR AT THIS
POINT -- MAYBE AT NO POINT --
BUT WE HAVE NATURAL GAS, WHICH
IS REALLY, REALLY
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY.
WHO HAVE ALL SORTS OF THINGS --
WE ARE THE NUMBER ONE IN THE
WORLD NOW IN ENERGY, WE’VE DONE
A GREAT JOB WITH ENERGY, AND YOU
LOOK AT WHAT YOU ARE PAYING,
PRICE PER GALLON ON YOUR CAR,
PEOPLE ARE SAYING IT IS
UNBELIEVABLE, THEY’RE PAYING
LESS THAN $2 IN MANY PLACES,
GOING DOWN, AND I CAN’T BELIEVE
HOW WELL WE HAVE DONE, WE DON’T
NEED TO BE IN THE MIDDLE EAST
OTHER THAN FOR THE PROTECTION OF
ISRAEL.
THERE IS NO REASON TO BE THERE
FROM THE STANDPOINT OF OIL.
BUT WE HAVE ALLIES, SAUDI ARABIA
AND OTHERS, THAT HAVE REALLY
SPEND A LOT OF MONEY HERE, AND
TREAT US WELL, AND WILL TAKE
CARE OF A LOT OF OUR PEOPLE --
WE HAVE SOME VERY GOOD ALLIES
OVER THERE, AND ISRAEL, OF
COURSE, WE HELP ISRAEL A LOT.
WE TOOK OUT SOLEIMANI.
WE TOOK OUT -- A LOT OF
PROBLEMS, THEY WERE HAVING OVER
THERE, OR THEY WOULD HAVE
WITHOUT US.
WITHOUT US, I DON’T THINK ANY OF
THEM WOULD SURVIVE FOR VERY
LONG.
SO -- BUT WE DON’T NEED IT FOR
ENERGY ANYMORE, WE ARE ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
IT IS AN INCREDIBLE FEELING.
I GUESS THE FIRST TIME WE HAVE
EVER BEEN -- OR AT LEAST FOR
MANY, MANY DECADES -- ENERGY
INDEPENDENT, AND YOU LOOK AT THE
PRICE OF ENERGY, IF BIDEN EVER
GOT -- HE WAS TALKING ABOUT NO
FRACKING, VERY STRONGLY, AND HIS
SUPER LIBERAL RUNNING MATE, THE
MOST LIBERAL PERSON, MORE SO
THAN BERNIE, RATED THE MOST
LIBERAL IN ALL OF THE SENATE,
KAMALA, IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT SHE
SAID ABOUT FRACKING, THROW IT TO
BE ANY FOSSIL FUELS, WON’T BE
ANY FRACKING, AND THEY ARE ALL
DISCIPLES OF AOC, AND AOC PLUS
THREE, AND IT IS RIDICULOUS.
THEY CONSTANTLY TALK ABOUT NO
FRACKING, BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN,
HE SEES HIS POLL NUMBERS GOING
DOWN, HE SEES TEXAS WANTS OIL, I
SAY THEY ARE AGAINST GUNS, THEY
ARE AGAINST OIL, AND THEY ARE
AGAINST RELIGION.
THAT DOESN’T DO WELL IN TEXAS OR
PENNSYLVANIA OR NORTH CAROLINA,
OR JUST ABOUT ANY OTHER PLACE
THAT I CAN THINK OF.
AND IT’S -- YOU KNOW, IT’S
INCREDIBLE, BUT HE WILL CHANGE
IN AN INSTANT AND PRETEND LIKE
NOTHING EVER HAPPENED.
THEY’LL SAY, OH, NO, I’M OKAY
WITH FRACKING.
HE SAID IT THE OTHER DAY, BIDEN
SAID IT THE OTHER DAY, HE SAID,
NO, NO, NO, FRACKING IS OKAY, WE
ARE GOING TO GRANDFATHER IT.
WE ARE GOING TO DO SOMETHING
WITH IT, BUT FRACKING IS ALL
OKAY, YET HE JUST RAN MONTHS AND
MONTHS OF FIGHTING FRACKING, AND
SHE -- I DON’T THINK SHE COULD
POSSIBLY SAY, SHE HAS BEEN
FIGHTING -- BUT THE BOTTOM LINE,
THEY WILL GO BACK BACK TO WHERE
COME FROM, AND WHERE THEY COME
FROM IS NO OIL, NO FRACKING, NO
DRILLING, RELIGION -- LOOK AT
WHAT THEY ARE DOING TO RELIGION.
THEY DON’T LET YOUR CHURCH IS
OPEN.
THEY LET A CASINO OPEN, BUT THEY
WON’T LET YOUR CHURCHES OPEN.
THEY WILL LET PROTESTERS PROTEST
IN THE STREETS WITHOUT MASKS BY
THE THOUSANDS, BUT THEY WON’T
LET YOUR CHURCHES OPEN.
SO IT’S RELIGION, ITS OIL, AND
ITS GUNS.
AND THOSE THREE ITEMS ALONE, HOW
CAN ANYBODY EVEN RUN --
GEORGE WASHINGTON AND
ABRAHAM LINCOLN, AS A COMBO, AS
A COMBINATION, COULDN’T WIN.
BUT THIS IS WHAT WE’RE UP
AGAINST.
THEY CHANGE THEIR VIEW, BUT
WHERE THEY ARE GOING FROM, AND
WHERE THEY ARE GOING TO, IS
WHERE THEY ORIGINALLY CAME FROM,
AND THAT IS NONE OF THIS STUFF,
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO FRAK, YOU
ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE ENERGY,
AND OUR NATION IS GOING TO HAVE
ONE OF THE BEST YEARS EVER HAD
NEXT YEAR.
LAST YEAR WAS THE BEST YEAR
WE’VE EVER HAD, NEXT YEAR IS
GOING TO BE BETTER, AND THE
THIRD QUARTER COMING UP, AND THE
ARE GOING TO BE OUT BEFORE THE
ELECTION, THOSE NUMBERS ARE
GOING TO BE FANTASTIC, YOU
WATCH.
>> Sean: WELL COME THE NUMBERS
WERE AT 8.4% UNEMPLOYMENT, SOME
PREDICTIONS EARLY ON -- I DO NOT
THINK YOU’D SEE THE JOBS COME
BACK AS QUICKLY AS THEY DID, TO
BE VERY --
>> President Trump:
RECORD-SETTING.
RECORD-SETTING, SEAN.
>> Sean: BUT EARLY VOTING HAS
STARTED.
BEFORE THE FIRST DEBATE, WHICH
IS SCHEDULED FOR SEPTEMBER 29TH,
EARLY VOTING AND STATES AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT THAT.
ARE YOU PREPARING YET FOR YOUR
UPCOMING DEBATES, AND IF SO, HOW
SO?
>> President Trump: WELL COME
A LITTLE BIT, BUT WHAT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT HER ALL OF THESE
BALLOTS.
THEY ARE SENDING UNSOLICITED
BALLOTS, COULD BE AS MANY AS
80 MILLION THROUGHOUT THE
NATION, AND WHEN YOU HAVE SMALL
RACES, LIKE A CONGRESSIONAL RACE
IN NEW YORK, WITH TWO PEOPLE,
WHERE THE BALLOTS ARE A MESS --
>> Sean: 84,000 PLUS.
>> President Trump: YEAH, THE
BALLOTS ARE MISSING, THEY ARE
GONE, THERE HAS BEEN FRAUD,
THERE HAS BEEN DECEIT AND
DECEPTION, AND THIS IS JUST A
SMALL CONGRESSIONAL RACE.
CAROLYN MALONEY, A SMALL
CONGRESSIONAL RACE, AND THEN YOU
LOOK AT NEW JERSEY, WHAT
HAPPENED IN PATTERSON, WHAT
HAPPENED IN VIRGINIA, WHAT
HAPPENED IN A MOST EVERY
PLACE -- AND THESE ARE SMALL
LITTLE RACES THAT ARE EASY --
YOU WOULD THINK IT WOULD BE VERY
EASY, BUT IT’S TERRIBLE, AND NOW
WE ARE SENDING OUT 80 MILLION
BALLOTS, AND THEY ARE
UNSOLICITED.
SO WHEN YOU SEND OUT -- THAT
MEANS PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GET BA
THEY ARE GETTING THEM.
AND THAT TAKES THE ENTHUSIASM
AWAY A LITTLE BIT, BECAUSE WE
HAVE MASSIVE -- THE LARGEST
EVER, THEY SAY, THE DIFFERENCE
IN ENTHUSIASM, BUT IF PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO START WALKING UP TO
YOUR DOOR AND SAYING, "YOU WANT
TO SIGN THIS TO VOTE," WILL SIGN
IT, I WILL SIGN IT, THERE IS NO
ENTHUSIASM NECESSARY THERE, IT
IS REALLY A CORRUPT SYSTEM,
THEY HAVE A PLAN, AND IT IS NOT
A GOOD PLAN, THEY WANT TO TIE IT
ALL UP, BECAUSE THEY CAN’T
CONTROL THE BALLOTS ON A SMALL
CONGRESSIONAL RACE AND SMALLER
RACES EVEN THEN THAT, IN THE
MALL, YOU ARE GOING TO CONTROL
80 MILLION BALLOTS?
I DON’T THINK SO.
>> Sean: ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR
HAS WARNED ABOUT IT, THE
HERITAGE FOUNDATION HAS
IDENTIFIED ALMOST A THOUSAND
CONVICTIONS ON THE ISSUE OF
VOTER FRAUD, ALMOST 1300
EXAMPLES OF VOTER FRAUD, YOU
KNOW, THE ELECTION IS NOW,
ANECDOTALLY, THERE’S BEEN
REPORTS THAT MAY BE OUR CAMPAIGN
IS SHORT ON CASH.
I MADE SOME CALLS TODAY.
MY SOURCES SAY THAT IS NOT THE
CASE, THAT YOU HAVE --
>> President Trump: NO.
>> Sean: YOU ARE SHY OF
$300 MILLION, BUT I WAS TOLD BY
A FRIEND IN FLORIDA THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS 3 TO 1 ADS RUNNING
AGAINST YOURS, IS THIS A
STRATEGY, YOU ARE WAITING, OR IS
THIS SOMETHING THAT YOU DIDN’T
WANT -- MAYBE YOU ARE JUST
RAMPING UP AFTER LABOR DAY?
>> President Trump: SO, FOUR
YEARS AGO, I WANTED IN THE LAST
MONTH, AND WE HAVE ABOUT THREE
TIMES MORE CASH -- THAT IS
WITHOUT ME PUTTING UP ANY -- IF
I NEED EXTRA, I WILL PUT IT UP
MY SHELF, I SAID THAT TWO DAYS
AGO, I SAID IF THERE’S ANY
NECESSARY EXTRA CASH, BUT WE HAV
A LOT OF MONEY COMING IN
AND SMALL DONORS.
WHEN YOU CALLED BIG DONORS, YOU
SORT OF PUT YOURSELF IN A VERY
COMPROMISING POSITION, WHEN
SOMEBODY PUTS UP A LOT OF MONEY,
YOU ARE IN A COMPROMISED
POSITION.
WHETHER YOU SAY IT, WHETHER YOU
DON’T SAY IT, BECAUSE DOESN’T
MATTER.
WHAT I LIKE ARE THE SMALL
DONORS.
WE HAVE SUBSTANTIALLY, TWO TO
THREE TIMES MORE THAN WE HAD
FOUR YEARS AGO AT THIS TIME COME
IN FOUR YEARS AGO, WE WON, BUT
IF WE NEEDED ANYMORE, IF I
SAW THAT WE NEEDED MORE, I WOULD
PUT IT UP MYSELF, ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, WE
HAVE AN ELECTION, WE HAVE LESS
THAN 20 SECONDS FOR YOU, AN
ELECTION IN JUST 55 DAYS.
20 SECONDS, WHAT THIS MEANS TO
YOU, THE SELECTION, AND WHAT
DOES IT MEAN TO THE COUNTRY?
>> President Trump: IF AND
WHEN WE WIN, WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE THE GREATEST ECONOMY AND
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
IT WILL BE NEXT YEAR, AND YOU
WILL BE NO MAXI NUMBERS LIKE
YOU’VE NEVER SEEN, WITH TAX CUTS
AND REGULATION CUTS, FURTHER, AL
DONE THE BIGGEST TAX CUT IN
HISTORY, GOING TO KEEP OUR
MILITARY AND OUR VETS VERY, VERY